so my phone rings on Monday and who is
it but the next guest here on the Rich
Eisen show the director of both of these
films the director of Hoosiers and Rudy
David anspach here on the Rich Eisen
show how are you David I love you it's
so exciting to be here i I just have to
Lester I just have to tell you I love
your your I guess you could call it a
rant the words that you had on Tuesday I
believe it was because you spoke for so
many of us thank you for that and and
you're talking to somebody who's going
to be turning 74 in September so I've
seen a lot of American history go down I
never in my lifetime in my lifetime
dreamed that I would be witnessing what
we're going through today and and it's
funny because you mentioned on Tuesday
you know when you said to your audience
I don't know what you want to hear right
now do you want to talk sports do you
want to you know so in in in in all due
respect my heart is there and now we can
get on with the game of Thrones movie is
a scam
who said that Notre Dame had the corner
the Marches yes
morally oh my god yes yes David yes
those are all questions I posed David
those are all questions I posed to the
house that landing in Rudy country house
that landing in Michigan I love Michigan
I grew up in Indiana that's where I live
now I went to Indiana University and
that's where I met the writer Angelo
pizza and when we met we we sort of
bonded over our love for movies and the
one speaking of 500 and I love Graham
Rahal and one of my good friends
Oriol Serbia was his teammate for a
couple years
2017-2018 I think maybe 20 to 14 and is
bad I mean they're great guys I wish him
really well too what was I talking about
you're talking about you meeting Angela
pizza and and how this is all landing
in country Michigan Michigan was my
first recruiting trip out when I was in
high school as a quarterback but I
wasn't much bigger than Sean asked and
so they gave me a meal ticket and a game
ticket and said have a nice afternoon
and they took my hat back who-who ended
up going to Purdue
so we could have we could have had a
movie about about somebody who's what
1/2 nothing 400 pounds nothing could
have called it David huh and then we
could have had Bo we could add Bo up
there and everybody could have put their
Michigan jerseys on the desk but that
really happened David you got me going
cuz the other night I just go by yeah
how much of this blank is true and I
started putting in yes a list of sports
movies ok you know we are Marshall The
Blind Side Remember the Titans blah blah
blah we come off like a Ken Burns
documentary compared to most of those
I'm not you know if you follow Rudy's
timeline in that movie yes of course we
took dramatic license of course and by
the way oh speaking of the Jersey see
yes you did see we are Marshall I'm
assumed yesterday and you remember when
the player comes in and they're having
the big what presidents board meeting
whenever like 50 guys in a room and he
said no no Marshall does need football
as a matter of fact come here it takes
him over the window and there's half the
campus outside never happened not happen
now that in the spirit of the truth
because I'm sure the student body and
all those people their hearts were in it
and and and that was why the scene was
written and true it was a group of
defensive players that went not to Dan
Devine who was a head coach but they
went to coach Ianto who is the defensive
coach and ask that any one of them said
we'll give up our Jersey so that Rudy he
should dress for one game because
Parseghian did promise in that and and
and he got that crap
beat out of him every day for two years
going to those practices and never
missed a practice and they said he
deserves it so so so sensual oh yes in
the spirit of the truth that he really
represented the feelings of most of the
players on that team maybe not everybody
I don't know pretty much so what about
the question of being carried off the
field David no I know you are I'm just
saying maybe you can Googlers it's the
whole crowd chanting rudy is there
Charles Dutton slow-clapping on the
other side of the wall David well if
you're asking if that all happened I
will tell you this the crowd did chant
Rudy and the only people on the the day
that Rudy played against Georgia Tech
the only people that knew the student
body knew about Rudy and the cheerleader
started to chant or maybe some of the
guys on the bench or whatever but it
spread around the stadium I've talked to
people that were there that heard it now
what happened on the day that we shot it
I literally shot the entire footage of
getting their quote money shots of you
know having Sean we didn't have the
money for CGI you know I could have shot
that at an empty state I could've shot
at a high school you know on it Oaks
Christian or something and it would have
looked like Notre Dame Stadium but we
didn't have that money so I had to shoot
Sean coming out of that tunnel against a
real crowd and I had to have him on the
sidelines with a real crowd behind him I
had him running on the field making a
tackle and being carried off so we
rehearsed the choreography of those
scenes four weeks after practice when we
go to our practice field and it was
literally like like a ballet night my
oldest daughter who's a who's a
professional choreographer contemporary
dance choreographer would have been very
proud but it was it was like about
because we shot at all in seven minutes
David Anspaugh director of Hoosiers and
Rudy here on the Rich Eisen show and
speaking of Rudy said getting the crap
beaten out of him
you want explain to me how what you told
me on Monday that Rudy has heard what
I've had to say about I haven't told my
guys what about this but please I give
you the floor is it's true that Rudy
that this what I have said into this
microphone has filtered in the direction
of mr. Ruettiger and it was very
interesting I have not talked to Rudy
Angelo has okay and apparently Rudy was
pretty incensed and sensitive enough to
go to his neighbor Mike Tyson and ask
him if he would train him to get you in
the ring to put the real Rudy in Las
Vegas next to Mike Tyson who he has
apparently asked for like training
advice so he could come along he could
you know I know that Mayweather it might
have been what was not in the movie is
that when Rudy was at Holy Cross and he
was you know you know trying to come off
as a Notre Dame student getting in the
cheering section paying helmets all that
he also joined what they called and I
don't know if they do it today but it
was a campus-wide
boxing tournament and it was called the
Bengal bouts and dudes he won it as a
Holy Cross dude masquerading as dude and
he won and we had it originally in the
script but we had to cut it out
well now hearing about his ability to
fight
what a great film this is David now that
story I mean wow it's uh it's quite a
moving piece of cinema that you put
together you talk about reality in
movies especially in sports films Angelo
went to Milan Indiana too when when when
he finally was going to sit down and
write Hoosiers anyway you went a
interview to all the players and people
in town and coaches and everyone right
and he came back to LA and he said you
know I can't do there's no movie here I
can't do it come on
I said well place it he said nothing
happened they said I asked every player
jogging along oh yeah we all go was
there any problem oh one day Bobby plump
was late to practice had to run some
laps that was about it
so he literally had to come back to LA
and I said okay I've got to I've got to
make this all up it's also funny because
a lot of people think that Hoosiers is
the Milan story and it certainly was
inspired by that and I grew up playing
high school basketball not in the 50s
but in the 60s and I wanted to make it
as truly informed as I possibly could
you know so you're telling me with me
saying how much fake Rudy is you're
saying Hoosiers even though that school
did know even though the school did win
but in terms of coach Dale and his
backstory and who he is and the picket
fence and Ally my team's on the floor
this is incredible wow you are having a
come-to-jesus moment I told you I had a
recruiting trip to Michigan and I only
had one other recruiting trip and it was
at Butler University and I it was an
honor for me I literally got to
interview with coach Tony Hinkle and the
funny to his office is in the Fieldhouse
where we shot the end of of Hoosiers and
which I had seen for the first
on the on the final day of the Indiana
high school basketball tournament they
and every coach and seniors tickets to
come see the final day of games never
ever forget walking into that place it
was walking into st. Peter's or or
something like that
I mean I'd never seen it was like a
cathedral I mean I got that feeling
sure and years I would go back for years
I go back every year the Fivefinger now
I live here but even when I was in LA
you know I had a string of 16 17 years I
didn't miss a race and every year I go
back and I would go in there my friend
and I would sneak in and I go way up to
the top of the building and I would sit
in the corner and I said you know if we
ever make this movie I've got to put a
camera up here one day to just see the
whole sweep of this place because your
people are so little play you know like
Hackman says at the end he's it is big
beautiful scenes David word he tells the
kids he loves them I love you guys that
they buy into his system and now he's
he's he's come around to and they're all
they're all one and and it's his time to
call the final play and and and and and
the kids the kids want Jimmy to take the
shot and he goes along with them all the
time it is a perfect movie it is a
beautiful film the stories though every
sports film needs a father-son story the
Dennis Hopper story with his son what
what what Gene Hackman does for these
kids it's amazing his his turn around
his story Jimmy Chitwood the whole town
wanting to run the coach out on the rail
but Jimmy makes them makes the move the
scene you have how many shots did he
make in a row free throws and then when
the coach tells him I don't care if you
don't play he misses the free-throw
David David well I paid the truth
whee-hee actually I'm gonna give away a
couple secrets here and which I think
some people have figured out but we
cheated a little in that see now first
of all I've talked a million people who
said wow that was so awesome you never
cut away in that shot yeah I saw him
make all those shots like well I did
kind of way I kind of wait twice I cut
to the ball going in and I cut to happen
or I cut to maybe Jimmy was but in
reality in the master tape that I've had
in my cut of the film until the studio
made me cut in those close-ups
he hit 15 in a row and literally when he
said I don't care if you play or not and
walked away he missed it dead-on missed
it and not on purpose
I did not direct that I mean that was
all that ever it was kind of like
deflategate deflategate we took a little
era sure okay you gotta help you gotta
help the process out a little bit and
what was happening like that a pure shot
very short did did you have to twist
Hackman's arm to do this or what David
oh that's rich
that's another show really um that was
one of the most unpleasant experiences
in my life and I think James performance
was I don't know you know as close to
perfection as well as one could get I
learned so much from him that was my
first feature film you know I had done
you know Hill Street and saying
elsewhere in Miami Vice no but that was
my first feature and to work with
someone of that stature not to mention
Barbara and Dennis and and all but Jane
was in almost every scene in the movie
and Jim was a
let's just say my only disagreeable it
was not fun for him I think well I'll
tell you this is a really great there's
a scene in the montage when hickory
starts winning yes uh and and there's a
shot of Dennis Hopper in the the cameras
across the floor and it's shooting
toward the Hickory bench and you see and
you got music going and you see hopper
and had been sitting there and you see
Dennis kind of laugh and slap his leg
mm-hmm
that was a reaction I didn't find this
out until just a couple years before
Dennis passed he finally told me yeah
don't you know what happened there
he said Hackman said to me Dennis I hope
you've invested well because we'll never
work again after this film he had no
belief in that movie or me at the time
so and now he admitted that when he
travels and stuff people of course pop
by of course you know French Connection
yet you know or maybe you know Batman
but probably more than anything it's
Normandale you know or people will yell
I'll make it coach or whatever but he
was brilliant but he was he was really
really difficult and part of it was my
nerves too you know III was too I was
trying to film a movie that I had been
dreaming about for nearly 20 years at
Angelo know I were trying to make and
the whole thing was very surreal
David telling you it's a beautiful
beautiful it is mine no I I do not
stutter and I've told you this when I
met you in person when I met you
personally I stayed here do it is my
number like I get this question all the
time except my profession my favorite
sports movie of all time
it's Hoosiers period and a story and I
am just so stunned that montage were
Dennis hoppers laughing and the shot is
a reaction to an off-camera line that
happen
saying that this movie is going to be
the end of our careers and Rudy is like
a Ken Burns documentary compared to
everything else including my favorite
movie of all time I mean I feel like I'm
on a ten game losing streak right now
but the other day it was funny because
you thought oh man I'm gonna get him now
but he did you know he said you know
every team he said what he said like we
had Rudy's on our team other guys and
most every team does a lot of them but
what he described and this is where the
air went out of your balloon was that he
said well these guys ended up getting
scholarships or contributed to the team
you know were real players you know and
they kind of got overlooked or they
didn't have enough scholarships and
these guys were genuine athletes but
Rudy was like just like Charles Aetna
said he was five but nothing a hundred
nothing he hung in with the best team
for two years and he got a degree from
Notre Dame that's what made it so
special you know and everyone telling me
and Angela when we lived in Indiana that
we were going to head west and our dream
was to you know somehow get involved in
the film business and one day to make a
movie based on Milan high school
and everyone laughed I mean literally
everyone laughed us out of the room you
know we had it we had a professor who
told us that we had a better chance of
you know walking on the moon than ever
achieving what we dreamed up my father
went through the same thing so many
people can identify that whether it's
scholastics or a musician or in bisque
whatever it is and that's why so many
people relate to the film no don't no
question David I love the Colts since
December 28 1956 when they beat the
Giants and I went out in the yard and
started practice throwing the football I
wore number 19 and recently in the past
few years
Joey United's his son asked me to direct
a movie about his dad
and was one of the great honors of my
life but I had to explain to him that I
can't do it there's not a movie there
because his dad was so talented and so
good he kind of got overlooked and they
finally discovered him it's like the
Rudy's that Kyle was talking about but
you know Rudy was he achieved what he
set out to do should one day I'm gonna
walk out on this field I'm going to
Notre Dame and everybody laughed at him
and and he did it and and you did it to
you and you and Angelo did it to David
this has been an amazing conversation
that was better than any of us could
have had hoped for or expected and just
to finish up I just have to correct you
you know the air will totally come out
of my balloon the minute that Rudy
Ruettiger bites my earlobe off because
that's what his neighbor told him to do
so that is where I think it will that'll
be the big day and in faded magazine oh
and I miss LA and my friends you're
listening I miss you all and let's all
be good and safe and oh by the way can I
just end with this one thing I called my
my daughter to tell her what time I was
gonna be on the deck yes and my and my
grandson is four years old gets on the
phone and he wants to talk to you said
I'm playing I'm playing baseball Bob
birdie and I said oh that's great
we're playing a baseball field I said oh
true and thinking he goes and I'm Jackie
Robinson and they were really he goes
yeah he was the first black player to
play baseball and he played in New York
but he doesn't play there anymore I
think they play in California yeah you
know when Korean said where do you begin
where does it start
and I said where did you get that idea
that somebody did your mom type know if
I read it in a book he had a book and
that made an impression on him and you
know don't give up hope you're the man
David thanks for the call let's stay in
touch we'll chat soon
thanks for the call today I appreciate
it it's a bit on spa
how great was that kind of puts a bubble
on everything doesn't it oh I don't want
to hear Rudy slander ever again I'm not
watching it ever again oh you're done
rich hey you watched all the way to the
end thanks for that watch more right
here